[Music]
hello everyone my name is Casey deers
I'm an assistant professor at UCLA and
integrative biology and Physiology
Department I've been with the bru family
since July of 2022 and I'm very happy
and thankful to the organizers for
allowing me to um share some of my
research that I have done and that I
will be doing while at
UCLA so first I want to talk about
Alzheimer's disease which is the most
common form of dementia the two Hallmark
pathological features of AD are
extracellular amid
plaques um and intracellular T Tangles
another key characteristic of
Alzheimer's these dementia is
Progressive cognitive decline as uh
shown here on the x axis some cognitive
decline is completely normal as we age
which is shown in the the green line
above however before overt dementia is
present individuals might show Brain
pathology of those proteins like Amid
and TOA before cognitive symptoms are
apparent to the individual or those
around them this is termed the
pre-clinical
stage as time progresses cognitive
impairment starts to become apparent to
the individual or those around them and
the person declines to dementia as
neurogeneration continues over time so
we have this doted line here that kind
of SE searates this preclinical stage
before symptoms are present and then the
mod cognitive impairment or MCI stage
and dementia stage when symptoms are
present so we can use something called
biological markers or biomarkers in
order to track these different stages of
of Alzheimer's disease dementia and it
is very important to note that the
different stages of Alzheimer disease do
not exist as discrete units they do
exist on a Continuum as shown here in
this figure if you look at the xaxis we
have those um those cognitive stages I
just talked about in the previous slide
normal preclinical MCI dementia on this
Continuum so in the preclinical stage
again we have these protein
abnormalities that can start to be
measured um so for example you have
amalo that can is usually apparent in
the brain up to 20 years before um any
dementia symptoms are present and then
even to um as shown here in the green
line is uh
present
um so and then as time progresses there
are other biological markers that start
to become apparent so for example um we
can use MRI or look at different an
anatomical features um and we start to
see that brain structure uh changes in
the brain structure so for example the
hi campus is really important memory
it's located in
the
atrophy um in people as they get closer
to the MCI
stage uh again um cognition typically is
not apparent until the um MCI stage when
it's mild cognitive impairment so the
name really matches uh when you start to
see different um abnormalities on the
neur psychological assessment testing
and so that's shown I think it's like
maybe a brownish purplish color I or
purple color um on the graph
and then of course you have the clinical
symptoms of dementia starting um around
the MCI dementia phase which is shown
and that's a brown line
so so there have been a number of genes
identified as either causitive or risk
factors for Alzheimer's disease as well
um so we have not only protein
biomarkers but we can also look at
genetics so a large number of these
genetic risk factors have been
identified from genomewide Association
study or gwa studies and so what's shown
here in this figure is what's called a
Manhattan plot um it's named that based
on the idea that it looks like a
Manhattan skyline so um on the x axis or
the bottom row you have the chromosomes
and on the y- AIS you have significance
and so if you uh look at uh the dots
that are at the top that kind of look
like the skyscrapers or peaks of the
Manhattan skyline these are actually uh
genetic variants that were significant
in the analysis and this analysis was
looking at um people with Alzheimer's
disease relative uh to people who are
cognitively normal so um this is
actually a very large Jos of around
39,000 people with uh clinically
diagnosed Alzheimer's disease about
47,000 people with proxy Alzheimer's
disease and related dementia cases and
just over 400,000
controls uh so this study actually
identified some of the same genetic risk
factors as previous dooses such as
apoe but also identified an additional
42 different Loi that were significantly
associated with Alzheimer's disease so
similar to the trajectories we see in
the previous slide these genetic markers
were largely defined in a European
population so the same question is uh
how do these risk factors uh not only
the biomarkers shown on the previous
slide looking at Amal to
neuropsychological assessments but also
genetic RIS factors how do all of these
biomarkers and risk factors how does
those trajectories look in the black
community considering what I've shown
you so far in the past two slides um
were uh identified in white
people so I wanted to talk about some
work from Dr Elizabeth Rosa she's also a
uh Professor here at UCLA an
epidemiology and this is actually
showing the incident rate for dementia
across different ethnic and racial
specialized groups and this is using
data from kaisa Permanente uh kaisa
Permanente in Northern California and um
you can see that people who
self-identify or have been racialized as
African-American or black um in the very
light blue on the leand side they have
the highest incident rate of dementia
relative to other ethnic and rer groups
including the white Group which is the
darker blue um and it's about
19.3 so the fact that most of those
established risk factors for Alzheimer's
disease dementia that I mentioned in the
previous slides has been identified in
white individuals is an issue this is an
issue considering black individuals are
at greater risk um are at a higher risk
for
dementia so I also want you know in line
with a lot of um Health Equity
researchers I wanted to build upon
something as well that Dr MAA uses here
um uh at UCLA and focusing on these
Health equity research goals so
ultimately we aim to identify drivers of
racial ethnic and other social
inequalities in health to inform
policies and programs uh to promote
Health Equity uh there are current
research efforts though focused on
describing Health inequality by group
and determining if these inequalities
are larger or smaller over time and
furthermore we also want to evaluate
specific risk factors and their
contribution to health inequalities is
key um as I mentioned the previous
slides because one size does not really
fit all when it comes to biomarkers and
trajectories and so and by that I want
to refer to the notion that yeah these
risk factors were identified in white
populations and may not have the same
effect in other racialized
groups so I'd like to start with an
example of why it's important to focus
on identifying risk factors in nonwhite
communities um so this plot shows a
global cognition on the y- AIS and so
higher is equal to a better cognitive
performance and then on the xaxis you
see age or which you can consider age
time as well so um this is going about
every two years from the ages of 68 to
90 and we can actually see two things
here first um at Baseline which is
highlighted in green uh so that Baseline
um being cross-sectional or just one
time point we see that black individuals
which is the dotted line Gray Line uh
have lower average cognitive per
performance relative to White
individuals um
oops however if we look longitudinally
so over time not cross-sectionally we
see that the slope of cognitive decline
is actually not different between black
and white
participants and I have this little
animation here to kind of so you can
compare a little bit better and I'll do
that again so this this draws are uh
highlights two really main important
effects first that there are raal bias
that exists in neuros pychological exams
um so neuropsychological testing was
created and validated in by by and in
white individuals so every group uh
every other ethnic and racialized group
that is not white tends to have a lower
intercept of uh cognition relative to
White individuals so this is an issue
right when we are using neur
psychological testing in order to um uh
classify person as having Dementia or
not and so if if we're using one time
point and we know that um uh black
individuals have this lower intercept
it's really important to remember that
to take into account some type of
normalizing process in order to try to
um uh understand what that score truly
means in Black
individuals and it also highlights the
need for longitudinal um studies in
Black cohorts because again if we you
know we look at the slope between the
two they are ident iCal which does
suggest that the neuropsychological test
is measuring the same cognitive function
in black as it is white individuals
however um longitudinal studies is
really needed to see any of that
effect next genetic risk factors are
also not the same in Black individuals
relative to White individuals so on
chromosome 19 lies two different genes
um that confer risk for cognitive
impairment and um Alzheimer's disease so
first is the APO lipoprotein e or
apoe and apoe has three alals E2 E3 and
E4 uh E2 is associated with lower risk
or maybe thought to be protective
against Alzheimer's disease E3 is
present in the general population and um
E4 is associated with increased risk for
cognitive impairment and Alzheimer's
disease and it does have a Dos so having
two ORS is associated with increased
odds um for Alzheimer's disease relative
to having one
E4 however so you might you might think
then okay E4 is bad so if you have more
E4 then you have have a higher chance of
developing
dementia um so if we look at black
individuals who are cognitively normal
that is the solid red bar in this graph
we can see that they uh this group
actually has a higher frequency of ape4
and that's on the y- axis so black
cognitively normal individuals have a
higher frequency of a pu4 relative to
White cognitively normal individuals um
which is shown in the solid blue bar and
the pattern bars next to the solid bars
are those with Alzheimer's disease so if
you look at the red and the blue pattern
bars for E4 um frequency you see that
they're almost identical so if E4 is
supposed to be this great genetic risk
factor for Alzheimer's disease then
shouldn't the pattern um bar for
Alzheimer's disease for black
individuals be higher but it's not so
this is really suggesting that there
must be some other Factor than E4 that
is actually contributing to ad risk in
Black individuals and this is true this
has been seen in a lot of different
studies from other groups that um uh E4
has a reduced or mitigated effect on
cognitive impairment and Alzheimer's
disease in Black individuals
and just to kind of show a little
translational um uh aspect of This
research uh there was a group that also
looked at uh E4 expression based on
ancestral background so um people have
admx genetic uh background especially
black individuals from um America um you
know due to transatlantic slave trade
atrocities that were done to our people
people who identify as black in the
United States who have been here for
Generations uh the genetic background is
highly ad mix between African and
European ancestry so that means a person
who has an apoe4 for example may have
gotten that E4 from their African
ancestral side or from the European
ancestral side so looking at E4
expression based on African or European
ancestry we actually see that Afric
people with a E4 and African local
ancestry actually have a lower E4
expression which is that purple relative
to
people who are E4 with European local
ancestry you can see a lot more purple
here meaning there's a higher expression
of E4 so this is really interesting
again just kind of showing here is this
really well-known genetic risk factor
for Alzheimer's disease yet it is not um
uh having the same expression on people
of different ancestral
backgrounds just Upstream of apoe is
another dream another Gene called Tom 40
um Tom 40 has a specific uh snip or
single nucleotide
polymorphism um it's that five RS 523
number there and this codes for T's so
at this location you just have TT t t TT
T's just a number a lot of T repeats and
if you look at the figure that's there
um this is just a histogram showing the
count on the y- AIS and the tom40 length
on the xaxis and you can see that in
general people um with this with this
specific um uh polymorphism have te's
between around 15 to
40 uh often Tom 40 has not really been
studied a lot in the past because Tom 40
is in linkage disequilibrium with apoe
meaning that it's like inherited
together and so because APO has such a
strong effect on Alzheimer's disease it
was thought that um the the effect that
people were seeing from Tom 40 was
really just uh um the the powerful
effect of AO
so of course most of these a Tom 40
studies were done in people who identify
as white and if you look at Tom 40 in
people who identify as black you can see
there doesn't appear to be much of a
difference however if you look at this
by apoe background or genotype you can
see that if you're white in E3 you have
poly repeats less than 20 or more than
30 and if your E4 and 520 um E4 you have
poly repeats between 20 and 30 so they
call this short long and very long now
if you're black in E3 you have a very
similar um uh variation of short and
very long but if you're black and E4
like wow the variation is just striking
right it's pretty much all over short
long very long this is very different
than y4 carriers and it has um and this
variation has yet to be really
investigated with other AD phenotypes to
see what this might mean for um for
black E4
carriers so for this study I use data
from Rush University and Rush University
has three amazing aging cohorts that
enroll at age 65 or older um and without
known dementia so they can follow them
over time and this these three studies
are the religious order study the rush
memory aging project and the majority of
the partic black participants come from
the minority aging research study which
includes black individuals from Chicago
and the surrounding suburbs um of which
Dr Lisa bronz at rush is um the P they
also have a very in-depth neuros
pychological battery and so looking at
all these different cognitive domains
such as visual spatial language episodic
memory working memory and all of these
um different cognitive tests are
aggregated to make a measure of global
cognition so we wanted to look at again
at that variation of black E4 carriers
and Tom 40 since there was um a lot of
different poly um repeat links so for
statistical sake we had to group these
um somehow so we decided to group them
based on on the short uh Al so um if you
have two shorts that's represented by
red and that's the same color in the
figure to the right as well if you have
one short Al that's represented by Blue
and if you have no short AO that's
represented by gold and so if we're
looking at the figure on the right now
we can see on the x-axis we have time
and years so on average these black E4
carriers had about eight years of follow
um cogni of follow-up and then on the Y
AIS we have Global memory and again
higher is equal to a better memory
performance or better cognitive
performance so we can see that if you
were black E4 and did not carry the Sher
which is represented in Gold you
actually had a significantly faster rate
of cognitive decline relative to if
you're black E4 and did carry a short Al
represented by the red and blue
lines now remember white E4 carries have
no variation um they're only represented
by um one line which is the black line
here we can see what I talked about um
earlier and that is if you look at just
time point0 cross-sectional it looks
like overall white and Y E4 carriers
have this better memory performance at
one time relative to all the black E4
carriers so this is very similar to what
I talked about at the beginning of the
presentation but when we look again at
the slope over time we do not see a
significant difference between white E4
carriers and black E4 carriers who do
not carry the short Al where we do see a
difference though is between white E4
carriers the black line and black E4
carriers who do carry a short Al which
is represented by the blue and red such
that these black um uh black E4 carriers
who carry short are just showing a
better a better a slower rate of
cognitive decline relative to the other
groups so when we're starting to look at
um black E4 carries and our other
studies if we're not taking into account
other genetic variation that is specific
to them that may be a risk for um
cognitive impairment or dementia this
may actually be you know muddying up our
our analyses a
bit and I think it's just also important
to not that there are very um other
non-apoe genetic risk factors that been
identified in Black individuals um this
is data from a recent gws asso study
that identified new common loai and
novel rare loai um in Black
individuals and then also I think it was
really interesting again if we're
focusing on people of ancestral
background there were two different um
Lite um that actually conferred risk and
protective um effects of dementia
um this pink line um they I don't have
the exact snip reported but this pink
line conferred lower ad risk for black
individuals so that's better lower risk
while the black line actually um
conferred higher ad risk for black
individuals so again there are other
genetic variants that we should really
be accounting for when we're looking at
dementia risk for black
individuals and I have been talking
about U genetics race and um genetic an
history a little bit in these slides and
so I think it's really important to
understand uh the terms before diving
more into the research um unfortunately
people have inappropriately correlated
race uh with one's biological background
race is not biological it is social
category forged through historical um
forged historically through oppression
slavery and Conquest um however race May
capture some important epidemiological
information such as socioeconomic
factors racism discrimination and
factors that heavily determine from
sexual racism and discrimination that
led to systemic policies such as red
lining for example race or more
corporately racism can influence every
aspect of love life um from Health Care
to education Green Space such as parks
and other Community
Resources genetic ancestry on the other
hand correlates more so with geographic
location since the catalog of genetic
diversity is gathered from people who
live in one area which also leads to a
question that I won't be exploring today
but that is genetic ancestry um but is
genetic ancestry also reflection of
environmental factors and potential
epigenetic changes additionally while
there are folks out there working hard
to change this there is a lack of
genetic diversity in reference panels
that are used to calculate genetic
ancestry in fact jwas catalogs are
roughly 80% European ancestry and only
2% African-American
ancestry um so understanding the
difference between race and genetic
ancestry is going to be crucial for the
ethical research um in the black
population uh yet another difference um
is postmortem neuropathological insults
are not the same in Black individuals so
here's a study by Lisa Dr Lisa barn at
Rush University and AD in blue just
means that pure ad pathology that is
these Amid and towel um pathologies I
talked about earlier um and as you can
see very few people to ad just actually
have amid T Tangles
um uh and in fact less black
participants have that true ad pathology
relative to White participants in that
the blue um blue wedges so um in fact
black individuals just have a much
higher rate of comorbidities and other
pathologies that may be contributing to
um overall cognitive um status and
dementia risk that we are overlooking at
this
time um and so just further going to to
an example of that uh you can see just
by looking at the years here for um
recent studies that have looked at
protein biomarkers there it's been very
recent um there hasn't been a lot of
work done in this area and um one thing
that is noticeable though is that there
is discordant amid findings uh whether
people found higher lower or no
difference in amid between black
individuals so this leads to yet another
study um that I did while I was at
Stanford University with Dr Morino and
that is looking at people with pre in a
pre-clinical Alzheimer's disease stage
and using amalo pet um to to look at um
the trajectory of amid in these
individuals or the levels of amid in
these
individuals so for this I actually use
data from the anti Amid and asymptomatic
ad or A4
study so on the xaxis you have API
genotype by um a a racialized group
black in red um and white individuals in
blue and then on the Y AIS you have a
amid uh levels so higher amid is
equivalent uh is worse so just by
looking overall you can see black
individuals have lower or better levels
of amid relative to White individuals
but what's interesting is that this
lower levels of amid is only significant
in Black E4 carriers so again we have
amid which is supposed to be this well
established risk factor we have E4 that
is supposed to be this wellestablished
risk factor for dementia and Alzheimer's
disease yet now we have shown multiple
times not only with the Tom fry AP study
but also here that here are other that
they're not having the same effect in
Black
individuals so if E4 is not conferring
the same risk what what is right we need
to be expanding um Beyond these
wellestablished risk factors um to look
for um potential effects
additionally looking at African ancestry
so again I talked about how people who
are black in the US have a highly
admixed genetic ancestry between both
European and African ancestry so shown
here is levels of African ancestry in um
red the red asteris and uh the blue
asteris the blue star is U levels of
European ancestry and so each person has
five um has five stars to represent the
five major groups that are shown at the
top of the graph so if you look at just
the very first column you can see that
we'll just call it participant one has a
African ancestry of around 28% and
European ancestry of around 90% however
this person does self-identify as black
so you can see that African ancestry
exists on this Continuum so I really
wanted to look at that as well so again
I'm showing increasing levels of African
ancestry on the
xaxis and amalo on the y- axis and again
higher amalo is worse as we see decreas
with increasing African ancestry we have
decreasing amid AKA better and this
effect was also independent of ameloid
so now we have um yeah another Factor
that's contributing to potential
protective factors against these
wellestablished ad risk
factors and another thing that's really
important though is looking at selection
bias in these studies um remember I
talked about earlier how the
neuropsychological test was validated
creating white individuals people who
are black always have perform at a lower
AKA worse level relative to White
individuals so could there be bias into
who's actually getting into the study
and indeed we see that black individuals
are more likely to screen fail and be
kicked out of the A4 study and why
because black individuals have too low
of cognitive test scores so the norming
procedures that are that are in place
right now to try to close that intercept
Gap in neuros pychological testing is is
clearly not working because black
individuals are still more likely to get
kicked out of these studies versus white
individuals who are more likely to get
um who were more likely to screen fail
out of the study due to having too high
of cognitive test
scores um and then I'm also just going
to briefly talk about you know I've
talked about this amid Imaging but also
um it's really important to also note
that there are M MRI measures of brain
aging so for example I talked about
there being atrophy in the metal
temporal L um uh amongst other areas in
the brain but what Dr andir attorney had
showed um from Columbia University uh in
people who identified as black if you
can look at the lower left um uh figure
there um what this shows is that there
are uh black individuals were more
likely to have earlier brain aging
relative to other groups so you can see
that the the two lines are kind of like
at a slant um showing these significant
differences relative to the other um
racialized and ethnic groups and so
brain aging occurs earlier in Black
individuals therefore us having these
cohorts at start at age 65 we're
probably missing a lot of um different
factors contributing as
well so this all ties back into the
health equity research what can we do
better how can we better service the
black community when we are doing our
research
and an example of this is really
focusing on the health disparities
research framework so let's not just
focus on the biological factors which I
have been to date but let also focus on
environmental sociocultural and
behavioral different factors um that
might contribute to these so um you know
a person doesn't just wake up at age 65
and then they start to have memory
decline these factors occur over the
life course and it's really really
important that we start collecting data
or asking questions about um a person's
life um and an example of that is from
uh Dr Crystal Glover also at Russia
University who organized uh the
different uh Health disabilities
research framework questions into how
does this associate with perceived
stress and I covered up the ones that
were not associated with perceived
stress but this is a way that you can
look at different factors and how it
Associates with with a um uh something
of Interest Perce like perceived
additionally something super important
that I'm very interested and we'll be
pursuing here at UCLA is looking at
structural racism and how that um and
discrimination and how that drives
Health disparities research so Dr um
Paris Atkins Jackson um at uh also
Columbia University has really done a
has really really great papers that are
looking at how to use structural racism
and discrimination appropriately and
ethically and it's important to you know
how does this tie in to to everything
doing um when we talk about the life
course a person experiencing racism
again that's usually something that has
happened over the life course exper
racism or discrimination is extremely
stressful this causes a lot of different
changes in the body and may eventually
cause changes in biological
processes so it is important again that
we still focus on tying in the social um
these social factors and here's an
example of that as well um from Dr Lura
zahodne um that show that uh
uh discrimination and racism are both
higher levels of discrimination and
racism are associated with um more hypoc
cample atrophy and higher white matter
hyperintensity
volume and this leads to the final goal
of the day and that is um just
implementing Health Equity Frameworks to
enhance participation of historically
excluded populations like people
racializes black often times racialized
groups are blamed for lack of
participation in research studies when
in reality it's the institution or the
researcher who has not put in the work
to Target these communities again I go
to the phrase like one size does not fit
all um and I myself have heard it's too
hard one too many times referring to
Recruitment and Retention of racialized
communities while I haven't actively
done this work myself I and I plan to in
the future I'm thankful for researchers
um uh as shown here um for people who
have done the work and put the these
Publications out in order to help people
such as myself who may want to do
research in the black community have
some type of start on how to um do
inclusive research uh for for the uh
black
community so um this this really
includes uh focusing on inclusion and
exclusion practices of research
participation targeted toward a specific
community and an example of this is
shown here by that model with its
research participation um and this is
called the participant in relationship
ship centered research engagement model
so this is just one model but um it is
extremely important again that we really
focus on Health Equity Frameworks in
order to best service um historically
excluded excluded straight up excluded
populations so again why research within
the black community is important within
this community black
individuals have a higher rate are more
disproportionately uh likely to be
diagnosed with dementia yet whiteness
continues to be centralized in research
again I'm talking about this GW was
catalog that shows about 80% of European
ancestry in the blue um while if you
look at the orange little wedge on the
bottom right side only 2% is African um
and this is really important because the
United States is becoming more diverse
this is data from the Census and you can
see for the first time that people who
identify as white in the United States
is actually on the decline while all
other ethnic and racial groups are on
the incline so it's going to be really
really important that we bring bring
these health eer research Frameworks um
to to non-white communities including
the black
community and this leads to um my my
research at um UCLA now and this is
really looking at the intersection of
biological and social factors how it
impacts brain aging and cognition and
and Alzheimer's
disease and I am new to UCLA so I don't
have a lot of uh I don't have't I
haven't shared any research that I've
done here because it's still ongoing and
not published um so a lot of this work I
showed was actually done at Stanford
University um with Dr Beth mormino and
in collaboration with Dr Lisa Barnes at
Rush
University and I always like to take a
moment uh to thank the women of color
that are scientists in my life because
it ha it is extremely hard to um be a
woman of color in this field and without
their support I would not be where I am
today and so with that I would like to
thank you for listening and um I hope
you enjoyed the the
lecture